this is Rick the shuttle will be to
report on Bourbon Street trying to find
out who's the best aunt down for Richard
Sherman or Darrelle Revis who's the best
corner in right now between the Richard
Sherman Bourbon Street yeah anything can
happen on Bourbon Street you guys played
against both Darrelle Revis and Richard
Sherman this year who's the better lock
every good fats low fat and slow yeah
okay and he looked at in the bucket and
he took drugs and he should have been in
play he got through it peel in Rihanna's
he just shut down corner either said
therefore cookie arenas that long
Richard Sherman nice to meet you are you
shut up are you here it's your service
I'll meet you I'm sorry his all cats are
that's all good it's all good it's all
good you got
who do you think is the better lock down
corner Oh Revis no doubt no doubt no
absolutely I respect the player I'm a
Patriots fan you gotta respect the
shutdown Revis Island play okay so
that's your standard talent yard for
challenge over you're not being Revis
you never heard of entertainment Tom
Brady no what's your shirt
calcium I love this guy
Richa Sharma nice to meet you all your
riches should I ever to jump yeah you
have her go I got has a hell of a handle
look back soon
Darrelle Revis or Richard Sherman I
don't go Revis try not to get on TV not
on TV just leave her honey I'm not at
the Super Bowl we're okay we're sorry
Aubrey's number one corner seats number
one question because Richard Sherman's
on the adderall doom is that really you
already know no nice to meet you Richard
Sherman you are I am Richard pleasure
hey go knighted Oh without a clown
question who's the better lock that
corner Sherman Sherman sure why do you
pick him cuz he plays yes my Niners
twice any time when we be talking trash
Tom Brady have some awesome awesome
Richard Sherman nice to meet you
haha this guy right here Sherman he
always say that he the best lockdown he
ate he physical but the real is a lot so
you realized that guy had interceptions
this year thank you I'm blaming you not
him you should have kicked the field but
when you had the chance but you know
what don't count them out they're coming
back oh sure oh my god right here oh my
god complete your report this is